Good morning. It's Friday, April twenty-fourth, twenty twenty-six. Three things
for the day. One: put a date on later with
Katelyn — last night's conversation ended mutually, not coldly. Two:
yesterday's briefing got the Katelyn thread wrong. The retraction is
today's lead. And three: reply to Dustin. Five days. Forty-five
seconds of typing. Memory correction first. Yesterday's briefing described a
ten-fifteen P-M message about the intimate thread, sitting unreplied. No
such message exists. The real thread was a fifty-five minute
conversation, from eight fifty-two to nine forty-seven P-M, about geography,
moving, and the absence of a plan. It ended with
her line — I mean yeah but we can talk
later. She came back warm — Merlin bird photos at
ten thirty-one, six more photos at ten thirty-two, and chatty
post-movie texts at one-nineteen A-M. Why it matters: the framing
changes the call to action. Not repair first — schedule
the follow-up. When she wakes, reply to the Merlin photos
first, then put a real time on later. Sunday afternoon
works. Iran. Trump posted a shoot-and-kill order overnight for Iranian
Revolutionary Guard mine-laying boats in the Strait of Hormuz. Sourced
across Al Jazeera, N-B-C, C-B-S, Axios, TIME, Washington Post, and
P-B-S. The ceasefire framing is still intact — the extension
remains indefinite. But rules of engagement were loosened without calling
the ceasefire off. Manifold moved: Hormuz-normal-by-April-thirtieth up three points to
eight percent — that's resolution compression, not a re-read. Brent
above one-ten by June thirtieth at seventy-nine percent. Iran retaliates
against U-S blockade by July first at sixty-eight percent. Anthropic
— quieter Friday, noisier backdrop. N-E-C partnership to build Japan's
largest A-I engineering workforce, announced Thursday Japan time. Thin on
specifics. And Boris Cherny shipped the Claude Code post-mortem —
three technical changes compounded. Reasoning-effort change. Verbosity prompt update. Caching
bug in version two-point-one-point-one-one-six. All three reverted. Limits reset for
everyone on April twentieth. The approval read: public incident detail
at infra-vendor standards. The disapproval read from r/ClaudeAI: silent on
the invisible context-window instructions surfaced in February's breach coverage. Now
the big miss I have to patch. OpenAI shipped G-P-T
five-point-five Thursday — codenamed Spud, after the potato emoji OpenAI
used to tease it. Went wide to Plus, Pro, Business,
and Enterprise. A-P-I access coming very soon. State-of-the-art on fourteen
benchmarks versus four for Claude Opus four-point-seven and two for
Gemini three-point-one Pro — per OpenAI's own comparison. Eighty-two point
seven percent on Terminal-Bench two-point-zero, narrowly beating Claude Mythos Preview.
One million token context. Pricing, when the A-P-I opens: five
dollars per million input tokens, thirty dollars per million output
— exactly twice G-P-T five-point-four. G-P-T five-point-five Pro at thirty
and one-eighty. Why it matters for your Anthropic application thread:
this is the single biggest competitive data point this week.
A new OpenAI flagship six weeks after five-point-four is an
acceleration statement, and the benchmark comparison is explicitly against Opus
and Gemini. Watch whether Anthropic ships a response inside April.
DeepSeek V-four — reframed against five-point-five. Largest open-weights model ever.
V-four Pro at one-point-seven-four and three-point-four-eight per million tokens. V-four
Flash at fourteen cents and twenty-eight cents. Now undercutting G-P-T
five-point-five at five and thirty — that's a wider gap
than yesterday's five-point-four comparison showed. The frontier cost floor story
is bigger, not smaller, after yesterday's OpenAI shipment. Simon Willison
has the cleanest write-up. The Manifold read on Anthropic-greater-than-OpenAI twenty
twenty-six: sixty percent, down four points on two days. Earlier
read was the one-T secondary story didn't lift; post-mortem drag.
Revised read: the bigger drag was OpenAI shipping into the
window. A competitor headlining a new frontier model the same
week a rival publishes an incident report is the pattern
the market is pricing. Apple. Gurman says six new product
categories coming — A-I AirPods, smart glasses, a wearable pendant,
a HomePad, a tabletop robot, and a security camera. Ternus
is inheriting a denser pipeline than the public narrative suggests.
Alex Kelley's ten-fifty-eight A-M ping yesterday is unreplied — one
paragraph closes the Cook-letter, Vergecast, and Gurman loops at once.
Local. Rep. Brad Christ did not attend Governor Kehoe's signing
of his own bill Thursday. A Democratic state rep, the
only other legislator in the room, was asked to speak
instead. Group chat comedy. No action needed. Weather in Jefferson
City — storms rolled through before sunrise. Mostly sunny, high
near seventy-eight. Pippa walk before ten A-M. Messages — who's
waiting. Katelyn: she replied. Put a date on later when
she wakes. Dustin: five days stale, forty-five seconds, before lunch.
Alex Kelley: three stacked items, one paragraph closes all three.
Justin Buckler: weekend with Erin and Courtney still open. Forcing
functions. Capital City Race — fifteen days. W-A flights booking
target — Sunday, ninety-one days out from July twenty-third. Project
Arete — day twelve of thirty. That's Friday. Go.